tras el estallido social y la llegada de
la izquierda a la casa de la moneda de
la mano de Gabriel boric Que ha cambiado
en este tiempo o qué ha hecho mal la
izquierda para este giro del sentido del
voto
bueno ha habido yo creo es una
combinación de factores es muy difícil
reducirlo a uno en primer lugar yo creo
que hubo una serie de errores tempranos
del gobierno de boric que tuvo que ver
sobre todo con la composición del primer
gabinete que era un gabinete con poca
experiencia donde en algunos ministerios
claves con el Ministerio del interior
había alguien que no tenía trayectoria
política y en otros con el Ministerio
secretaría general de gobierno que es el
Ministerio clave para articular
digamos y negociar con el con el
congreso no teníamos buena llegada con
los legisladores Pero además yo creo que
también hay un desgaste hubo una
imposibilidad de pasar alguna de las
reformas claves la reforma tributaria la
reforma previsional y por último un
escenario económico sumamente complejo
con una con una inflación en aumento y
un descontento y un desgaste de la
ciudadanía muy fuerte Entonces yo creo
que hay una serie de factores que se
combinaron para terminar en este
escenario
bueno esta victoria de la derecha y de
la extrema derecha dará lugar
directamente a un texto muy escorado a
la derecha o buscarán consensos para que
el texto no sea rechazado
Mira a ver el texto no necesita el de la
primera instancia digamos porque como
ustedes bien decían al inicio con
treinta y cuatro consejeros la derecha
puede básicamente
lograr el texto que que quiera ahora Lo
que sí es probablemente que veamos es
que con esta con esta composición en el
consejo va a haber una una intención de
mantener el statu quo es decir el
estatus quo que prevalece al día de hoy
es la constitución que teníamos que
muchos asocian con la Constitución de
pinochet verdad Entonces es muy unos
cambios ha habido algunas señales del
gobierno por ejemplo el consejero más
votado dijo estar absolutamente en
contra del aborto pero que sabía que
introducir al aborto por ejemplo a la
discusión ahora podía comprometer el
proyecto entonces que no se iban a meter
con ese tipo de temas con lo cual es
probable que algunas cosas de la agenda
valórica queden afuera para que este
proyecto avance
y bueno de salir rechazado un segundo
texto habría opción para una tercera
votación Constituyente o qué escenario
Se podrían abrir en Chile
Mira los escenarios son sumamente
complicados porque acá o sea nosotros
estamos analizando el proceso
Constituyente pero la derecha en este
minuto está analizando la carrera
presidencial es decir casi está jugando
a dos bandas en paralelo yo creo que no
hay incentivos por parte de la derecha
para que el proyecto constitucional
digamos muera acá es muy probable que
veamos un proyecto moderado el propio
discurso de cast Ayer fue bien
sorprendente en ese sentido no era un
caso muy alejado del discurso
tradicional de la derecha
tratando de
yo creo que
promover la calma digamos no y al mismo
tiempo el discurso de boric fue en la
misma dirección entonces yo pienso que
lo más probable es que haya un texto no
muy radical digamos un texto que tiende
a mantener el statu quo para que se
asegure su pasaje y este proceso
al fin se cierre